[Musique]
parmi les images les plus fortes de la
décennie écoulée il y aller fouler la
contestation des printemps arabes à
partir de 2011
depuis un certain nombre de pays ont
sombré dans le chaos et la guerre la
syrie le yémen la libye dont ont connu
une transition politique
la tunisie où une contre-révolution
l'egypte ce qui est intéressant c'est
que près d'une décennie plus tard on
constate qu'on manifeste toujours dans
certains pays de cette région ce qui
montre que les demandes politiques et
économiques des printemps arabes sont
toujours là le plus marqué pendant cette
décennie c'est la montée en puissance
des mouvements jihadistes
quand j'ai commencé à travailler ce
sujet ce n'était pas pris au sérieux et
nous on a vu cette montée en puissance
fulgurante en céréales déclaration du
califat expansion va de notre territoire
c'est l'asie du sud-est puis bien sûr
les attentats d'inscrits en france
charlie hebdo à janvier 2015 et les
attentats du 13 banques
alors moi ce qui m'a marqué dans les
années 2010 en amérique latine
c'est la progression des idées ultra
conservatrice voire réactionnaire dans
cette décennie la décennie précédente
elle avait été marquée par l'avènement
de gouvernements progressistes et les
gens s'en sont détournés et ont préféré
une vision plutôt autoritaire et
religieuses de la société
je me souviens très bien du 11 avril
2011 j'étais à abidjan c'est le jour de
la chute de laurent gbagbo
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que depuis
des mois vous avez alassane ouattara et
laurent gbagbo qui disent qu'ils sont
tous les deux d'un président de côte
d'ivoire et leurs deux camps
s'affrontent un conflit qui a fait 3000
morts est en fait dans les derniers
jours en fait la communauté
internationale qui avait elle reconnu la
victoire d'alassane ouattara a décidé
d'envoyer des troupes françaises le
trouble de l'onu pour faire chuter
laurent gbagbo et ce jour là avec mon
collègue johann bodin ont donc juste
après l'arrestation de gbagbo font sedan
à sa résidence qui était en flammes
et je me souviens très bien d'avoir vu
les soldats le prob à tara qui insultait
les cadavres des soldats pro gbagbo qui
jonchaient le sol et on s'est dit ce
jour-là que la réconciliation entre les
deux camps à les prendre très longtemps
[Musique]
ce qui m'a marqué pendant cette décennie
c'est la bataille de mossoul mossoul qui
est donc tombée aux mains de
l'organisation état islamique en juin
2014 elle est rapidement devenue la
capitale du califat en irak
et puis en octobre 2017 commence donc la
bataille pour la reprise de cette grande
ville
quelques jours plus tôt la coordinatrice
humanitaire des nations unies nous
convoque tous les correspondants sur
place
dans un aveu d'échec elle nous explique
que c'est une catastrophe humanitaire
programmés et en effet pendant neuf mois
nous assistons à un déchaînement de
violence
l'occident y est directement appliquée
puisque la coalition internationale
bombardait la zone
jusqu'à présent on ignore le nombre de
morts civils
mais on estime à plus de dix mille
personnes en économie l'événement à
retenir parce qu'il va nous bouleverser
pendant très longtemps encore c'est la
guerre commerciale lancée par donald
trump contre la chine les etats unis ont
un déficit commercial abyssal et le chef
de la maison blanche pense qu'il suffit
d'augmenter les taxes pour rétablir
l'équilibré
ça ne marche pas c'est la guerre et
cette guerre c'est la fin de la
mondialisation dit heureuse entre
guillemets c'est aussi l'émergence de la
puissance chinoise
une nouvelle donne économique et
géostratégique
au cours des dix dernières années le
monde a pu prendre conscience de
l'ampleur migratoires des hommes des
femmes des enfants ont été poussés sur
les routes de l'exil à cause des
conflits des violences des persécutions
mais aussi de la pauvreté ou encore du
changement climatique ce qui restera
peut-être le plus dans les mémoires
c'est cette période de 2015 que l'on a
qualifié de pic de la crise migratoire
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ont alors pris la mer à destination de
l'europe
photo symbole de cette crise migratoire
celle du petit alan courdier retrouvés
échoués mort sur une plage turc à l'été
[Musique]
dans cette actualité parfois un peu
sombre il faut aussi voir qu'il ya des
avancées scientifiques et notamment dans
le domaine spatial qui sont
extraordinaires on a découvert ces
dernières années
4000 exoplanètes donc des planètes qui
sont en dehors de notre système solaire
ces planètes on les a identifiés
maintenant on les étudie pour savoir
lesquels sont les plus intéressantes qui
ont une atmosphère peut-être peut-être
de l'eau liquide
c'est une recherche fascinante on estime
qu'il y à plus de 100 milliards
d'exoplanètes donc dans notre galaxie
donc cela ouvre bien sûr des horizons
cela nous rappelle que notre planète est
extraordinaire et qu'il ya aussi plein
de choses à découvrir dans l'univers
[Musique]
l'événement médiatique de la décennie
côté environnement c'est là comme 21
c'était en 2015 quand l'accord de paris
a été adopté par plus de 195 pays
c'était l'évènement tout le monde était
ému cinq ans plus tard force est de
constater que c'est la grosse déconvenue
la grosse déception
aucun des états quasiment qu'il s'était
engagé à diminuer leurs émissions de gaz
à effet de serre ne l'a fait du coup la
jeunesse est dans la rue les tensions
sont plus en plus vive entre les
citoyens et leurs états et je pense que
la décennie à venir va être une décennie
d'affrontements et de lutte
ça risque d'être de plus en plus tendu
face et son orgue itunes
interview ce tournoi de wimbledon
lors des événements les plus marquants
de cette décennie c'est évidemment le
soulèvement du peuple algérien à partir
du 22 février 2019 il descend de
spontanément dans la rue pour s'opposer
un cinquième mandat d'abdelaziz
bouteflika
il démissionnera quelques semaines après
la mobilisation elle continue toujours
de manière exemplaire sous un même
slogan s'il n'ya qui veut dire pacifique
alors ce qui est marqué cette décennie
pour moi c'est l'hyper concentration du
pouvoir sur internet avec l'émergence
des femmes le gaf a c'est la pause et et
ça pose toujours beaucoup de questions à
commencer par celle de l'exploitation de
nos données personnelles
on a vu ce que ça donnait avec le
scandale quand médias les ti-cats en
2018 un accueil parfait
cela interroge aussi le rôle et le
pouvoir de l'état face à ces
multinationales dont les utilisateurs
les clients finalement se compte
désormais en milliards ce que je retiens
de ces dix dernières années octobre 2017
le début du mouvement mi tout une
révolution féministe qui aura
profondément un définitivement changer
notre société en permettant aux femmes
de libérer leur parole d'assumer la
place qui est la leur dans le monde est
bien aussi qui aura permis aux hommes de
ne plus être ce que le monde a toujours
voulu tout cela pour moi cette décennie
a été celle des lionel messi moi qui
avais beaucoup suivi dire maradona je
pensais qu'on ne verrait jamais rien de
similaire
et pourtant il ya une dizaine d'années
dix ans exactement j'ai connu
personnellement
lionel messi c'est y aller chez lui j'ai
vu ce jeune homme qui venait de gagner
son premier ballon d'or entouré des
siens et dix ans après avec son 6e
ballon d'or sous les bras je le retrouve
toujours égal à lui même est beaucoup
plus mûre beaucoup plus grand toujours
avec les mêmes le même entourage et je
suis heureux d'avoir vécu cette décennie
absolument magique
en suivant ces grands joueurs qu'est
lionel messi et on ne peut pas évoquer
cette décennie sans évidemment parler de
la victoire de l'équipe de france lors
de la coupe du monde 2018 je pense que
pour tous les français c'est un souvenir
inoubliable à ce moment là la france
entière est entré dans un état de liesse
toute la nuit après la victoire contre
la croatie et moi qui ai eu la chance de
travailler sur cette victoire de la
france puisque j'étais aux champs
elysées au moment où la france a soulevé
cette coupe du monde
et bien je peux vous dire que à ce
moment là c'était vraiment une nuit de
folie et je pense que ça sera des
souvenirs inoubliables pour tous ceux
qui ont la chance de vivre ce moment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]